on est lancé qu'est-ce que tu nous as
fait alors
je crois qu'ils ont permis
quoi il me semble
ah c'est assez vieux
intéressant on est sous un pont qu'on a
jamais fait donc voilà c'est la rivière
c'est le fleuve donc pas mal d'eau on
est en compagnie de Alex il y a Spotify
qui va bientôt nous rejoindre et il y a
Gaëtan qui est là aussi bien sûr
et ouais c'est prometteur ici c'est
assez profond
en direct
j'ai des câbles
j'ai des câbles bizarres
[Musique]
c'est bon signe
voilà on a quelque chose de gros quelque
chose de gros qui bulle bien
c'est venu c'est venu un peu je crois
non au début avant de lâcher
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on n'aura pas
fini
si vous avez besoin d'aide
[Musique]
ça c'est sûr
il y a une pierre avec un rocher avec
et le rocher dessus forcément c'est
lourd
je vous l'ai dit les gars
aujourd'hui
incroyable regardez il est fossilisé
magnifique
je pense on pourra pas le restaurer donc
autant le laisser que les rochers c'est
plus stylé je pense ah oui regarde
l'état il est mort mais c'est joli c'est
un truc français ça non à faire
magnifique
on va le prendre au soleil
oui mais je sentais le gars ici les gars
[Musique]
là je reconnais que il restera rien si
tu veux il y a pas de chargeur il y a
peut-être le chargeur par là bon super
parce que ça se trouve c'est un peu la
même époque puisque tu vois il était
au-dessus
les archéologues
qu'est-ce qu'on a de beau
ah c'est du bois non
[Musique]
OK
grosse quand même elle est plus grosse
que du cœur 98
est-ce qu'il y a une année là
en tout cas
même quelque chose
là on avait coincé un aimant on a envoyé
le deuxième pour le décoincer et souvent
quand on fait ça on arrive à coincer des
trucs entre les deux aimants et c'est là
qu'on fait les meilleurs trouvailles
ok
[Rires]
c'est quoi ça
quand même il est en métal
ils font des vins qui ont fait le
revolver que tu avais trouvé là un coup
en 22 c'est vrai que aussi la marque ça
fait chip hein
il est beau il est rigolo
mais ça doit valoir que dalle aussi ça
doit être les vraiment les pistolets qui
coûtent le moins cher
c'est quoi le bordel
pistolet
à 220
[Musique]
ok voilà donc une arme encore
allez deuxième gueule de la journée les
gars
on se met bien aujourd'hui
rasta tu les surveilles
faut pas oublier que kidi pêche à
l'aimait aussi pas mal de galère combien
de temps sur le treuil il y a combien
des mots coincé encore la 2 on peut
coincer un aimant mais pas deux
et le deuxième tu es justement Quentin
ok bon un aimant sauvé
pêcher des amplificateurs radio ou des
trucs bizarres qui ont des antennes
n'oubliez pas si vous voulez un bel
aimant passer par maison de la détection
ici on a le Barbarian donc c'est le plus
puissant 1600 kg mais vous avez une
gamme avec différentes tailles et
différents poids à partir de 800000
kilos c'est très très bien et c'est nos
partenaires donc on a un code pêcheur de
trésor qui vous offre 5% sur toute la
boutique à savoir qu'ils font des
aimants mais aussi des détecteurs de
métaux du 100.000 kilos
pas moyen de débloquer les mains donc là
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va passer
par le pont on va nous envoyer la corde
ouais facile ça fait déjà plus d'une
heure qu'on est bloqué qu'on peut pas
pêcher c'est aussi ça la pêche à
l'aimant dans les endroits compliqués
mais ça valait le coup parce que on a
fait quelques trouvailles déjà
allez vas-y tiens
voilà il va falloir peut-être monter les
aider en soi
je suis pas sûr qu'ils arrivent
avec Spotify on est maintenant en haut
du pont
on va tester quelques lancers même si
c'est pas notre spécialité nous du haut
du pont
et
ça va pas alors qu'est-ce que j'ai de
beau
j'ai quelque chose
une heure une arme
c'est quoi le bordel
ouais ça doit être ça
[Musique]
j'ai eu un truc direct
c'est trop lourd
es c'est trop chiant
c'est de la merde
ah ouais fais gaffe mon cousin
et j'ose même plus lancer la basse
[Musique]
la découverte
le feu
ça c'est de la belle
[Musique]
regarde
oh les gars regardez les tâches
pas c'est un Vespa aussi
[Musique]
salut
c'est
le marteau de Thor c'est le marteau de
Thor c'est le marteau de Thor
[Musique]
c'est loin
[Rires]
désolé Thor il est arrivé
oh merci en tout cas c'est quoi ces
démons qui a marché en fait
ça vaut le coup
j'étais un échafaudage complet en fait
sans déconner au coup ça coûte quoi vous
pêcher du poisson ici
ça va
comment c'est 1600 dans tous les cas ce
truc qui fait 100 kg c'est le maximum
quoi
après quand il y a des
motocrosses
c'est compliqué quand ils se coincent
pour les rochers surtout
et oui là-bas
du marteau de Thor
[Musique]
c'est une mâchoire il y a les dents et
tout avec
mais pas d'homme
vers l'avant
ça c'est un indice là dans vers l'avant
comme ça là mais ouais je sais pas si
vous savez en commentaire
[Musique]
on a besoin de toi pour identifier
on s'en fout encore une passerelle
d'échafaudage ce qui nous ont fait
amener la voix
c'est bon
là j'ai un truc bien je sens je le sens
non même pas c'est une
coupe
elle est grande
je crois que c'est un gars
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr
tu es sûr je compte sur toi pour la
restaurer
il faut s'imaginent surprise
c'est quand même très stylée
il est à quelle heure
il adore les boîtes de vitesse
attendez un peu
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait chien encore
juste là
c'est pareil
attends viens non c'est un aimant ah non
ça va c'est pas un humain parce qu'il y
a des trucs
je l'ai pas vu
j'ai mangé
j'ai mangé non
toi elle est sur toi ta casquette elle a
le droit
des coups de soleil ce soir
tu es sur un clic-clac ça
ah non c'est peut-être en fait c'est pas
une table
j'ai cru une table
alors
c'est très rare et ça qu'est-ce que
c'est
plaisir ça faisait longtemps
de très belles trouvailles ici encore
bravo
bien joué
le vieux cadre
sur la tête c'est bon Alex
ouais c'était un cadre
on va regarder s'il y a pas un truc
là-dedans
on reviendra ici pour une partie 2 et
d'ici là on vous souhaite de très bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année à la semaine
prochaine